AFTER THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH
LAST NIGHT AT 5, A LOT OF
AMERICAN BUSINESSES ARE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT OKAY I'VE GOT MORE
THAN 100 EMPLOYEES, WHAT AM I
GOING TO DO?
AM I GOING TO REQUIRE THE
VACCINE?
LET'S TALK TO ONE BUSINESS GUY,
BEN SHAPIRO IS THE HOST OF THE
BEN SHAPIRO SHOW AND ALSO
THE EDITOR OF THE DAILY WIRE.
BEN?
YOUR COMPANY HAS GOT OVER 100
EMPLOYEES SO WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO?
ARE YOU GOING TO LISTEN TO THE
PRESIDENT, EVERYBODY ROLLING UP
THEIR SLEEVES OR  ARE YOU GOING
TO TAKE A DIFFERENT APPROACH?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
WE'RE GOING TO USE EVERY METHOD
AND RESOURCE AT OUR DISPOSAL TO
DEFY THE PRESIDENT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ORDER AND THIS
IS COMING FROM SOMEBODY
WHOSE VERY PRO-VACCINE.
I WAS VACCINATED AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND I'VE ENCOURAGED
EVERYBODY TO GET THE VACCINE OR
PRETTY MUCH EVERYBODY TO GET
THE VACCINE AND THE NOTION
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
THE ABILITY TO FORCE EVERY
BUSINESS IN AMERICA WITH OVER
100 EMPLOYEES BY THE WAY I'M NOT
SURE IT'S OVER 100 EMPLOYEES IT
SHOULD BE EVERY BUSINESS IN
AMERICA.
RIGHT, BUT EVERY BUSINESS IN
AMERICA WITH OVER 100 EMPLOYEES
TO EITHER FORCE ITS EMPLOYEES TO
VACCINATED OR  FORCE THEM TO
TEST EVERY WEEK OR  FIRE THEM,
PRESUMABLY, HE SAID HE CAME INTO
OFFICE SAYING I'M NOT GOING TO
SHUTDOWN THE ECONOMY, I'M NOT
GOING TO SHUTDOWN THE COUNTRY
I'M GOING TO SHUTDOWN THE VIRUS.
AINSLEY: WELL, BEN, THEY SAY HE
SAYS JOE BIDEN'S BUSINESSES WHO
REFUSE WILL BE FINED $14,000 PER
VIOLATION.
YOUR CEO SAID THAT YOU WILL USE
LEGAL ACTIONS TO RESIST IN A
TWEET.
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THIS?
>> WE ARE.
I MEAN, WE ARE STAFFING UP RIGHT
NOW ON THE LEGAL SIDE.
WE ARE ALREADY GETTING ANY
LAWSUIT READY THAT NEEDS TO BE
GOTTEN READY.
WE HAVE THE ACTUAL REGULATIONS
AND KNOW THE DETAILS BUT WHAT WE
CAN TELL YOU IS THAT THE
PROVISIONS THAT JOE BIDEN IS
GOING TO BE CITING UNDER OSHA
ARE WILDLY OVERBROUGHT AND
FRANKLY HE'S MADE A HUGE
TACTICAL LEGAL BLUNDER AND
THERE'S EVERY POSSIBILITY THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS GOES TO THE
SUPREME COURT LEVEL AND WE SEE A
COMPLETE REWRITING OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STATE BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN COULDN'T GET HIS ACT
IN ORDER SO HE DECIDED TO ISSUE
A AUTHORITARIAN ORDER HERE.
BRIAN:  ALSO YOU HAD AN
INTERESTING TWEET GETTING A
LOT OF NEWS WHEN YOU SAID MAYBE
IF WE TELL JOE BIDEN THAT THE
TALIBAN ISN'T VACCINATED HE
WILL GET JUST AS MAD AT THEM.
DOES IT ASTOUND YOU THAT HIS
ANGER IS FOCUSED ON THE UN
VACCINATED IN AMERICA AS
SMALL PERCENTAGE AS THAT IS
AND NOT ON THE TERRORIST REGIME
THAT HAS TAKEN OVER OUR COUNTRY
AND THE EMBARRASSMENT OF OUR
NATION?
>> WE'RE NOT EVEN A YEAR INTO
THIS PRESIDENCY AND THIS IS A
FAILED PRESIDENT AND HE'S
ATTEMPTING REDIRECT ALL OF
EVERYTHING AT HIS PRESIDENCY AT
YOUR FELLOW AMERICANS, YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE ANGRY AT YOUR
NEIGHBOR FOR UNVACCINATING.
THEY EFFECTIVELY POSE NO THREAT
TO YOU INSTEAD JOE BIDEN WANTS
YOU TO BE ANGRY AT THAT NEIGHBOR
AS OPPOSED TO HERE.
HIM IS THE REALITY IF YOU DON'T
LIKE MANDATES LOOK AT THE PERSON
WHOSE ATTEMPTING ISSUE THE LOCK
DOWN AND THE MANDATES THE PERSON
ATTEMPTING CONTROL AMERICAN
BUSINESS TOP DOWN WHOSE
ATTEMPTING CONTROL EVERY SCHOOL
IN AMERICA, TOP DOWN, MAYBE YOU
SHOULD DIRECT IT AT THAT PERSON
NOT THE PERSON LIVING NEXT DOOR.
STEVE: SPEAKING OF NEXT DOOR,
YOU STILL LIVE IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU HAVE SINCE MOVED TO A FREER
STATE THAN THAT, A LOWER TAX
STATE AS WELL.
I WANTED YOU TO WEIGH IN ON THE
FACT THAT COMING UP NEXT
WEEK THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE THE
RECALL ELECTION OF GAVIN
NEWSOM IN CALIFORNIA.
HE VERY FAMOUSLY PRETTY MUCH
LOCKED DOWN ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
LARRY ELDER IS SURGING IN THE
POLLS, BUT HE WAS
ESSENTIALLY ACCOSTED.
LET'S SEE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN ON
WEDNESDAY, VENICE BEACH, WHERE A
WOMAN, SCREEN WRITES IN A
GORILLA MASK WITH A PINK WIG,
TRIES TO HIT HIM IN THE HEAD
WITH AN EGG.
WATCH THIS.
BRIAN:  WHAT'S YOUR REACTION?
STEVE: HERE IS LARRY ELDER LAST
NIGHT ON TUCKER.
WATCH.
>> SHE MIGHT BE ONE OF THE
20,000 PEOPLE THAT WERE
RELEASED EARLY FROM OUR PRISONS,
MANY OF WHOM WERE VIOLENT
OFFENDERS UNDER THIS GOVERNOR.
IF I WERE A DEMOCRAT OBVIOUSLY
THIS BE CALLED SYSTEMIC RACISM
AND CALLING IT A HATE CRIME.
I DON'T LIKE TO PLAY THAT GAME.
I DO KNOW THIS THERE WAS A BIG
ARTICLE ABOUT ME, A NEGATIVE IN
THE NEW YORK TIMES, AND NEVER
ONCE MENTIONED THAT I'M BLACK,
NEVER ONCE MENTIONED THAT I BE
THE FIRST BLACK GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA.
I NEVER MADE A BIG DEAL ABOUT
THAT.
I DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR
OR  AGAINST ME BECAUSE I'M
BLACK BUT AT THE VERY SAME PAGE
OF THE NEW YORK TIMES THERE'S A
BIG ARTICLE ABOUT THE FIRST
FEMALE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK.
EVEN THOUGH SHE DIDN'T GET
ELECTED SHE WAS BASICALLY
APPOINTED BECAUSE THE OTHER
GOVERNOR RESIGNED SO THEY CARED
ABOUT THE FIRST WHEN IT WAS A
FEMALE DEMOCRAT BUT COULDN'T
GIVE A RIP ABOUT THE FIRST WHEN
IT WAS A BLACK REPUBLICAN.
STEVE: BEN, YOU KNOW, THERE SEEM
S TO BE A DOUBLE STANDARD IN
THIS COUNTRY WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS.
>> OF COURSE, I MEAN, IF LARRY
ELDER WERE A DEMOCRAT WE KNOW IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN FRONT PAGE NEWS
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN TALK ABOUT
HOW THIS WHITE WOMAN THROWING AN
EGG AT A BLACK MAN WAS JUST
EVIDENCE THAT NOTHING HAS
CHANGED OVER THE PAST 150 YEARS
BUT BECAUSE LARRY IS A
REPUBLICAN AND CONSERVATIVE,
THIS MEANS LARRY IS THE ACTUAL
WHITE SUPREMACIST ACCORDING TO
OP-ED WRITERS FOR THE LOS
ANGELES TIMES AND THE WOMAN
WHOSE THROWING EGGS AT HIM WHILE
WEARING A GORILLA MASK IS AN
ANTI-RACISM ACTIVIST, VERY
STRANGE HOW NONE OF THIS HOLDS
AS SOON AS THE TARGET IS A
CONSERVATIVE.
BRIAN:  IF LARRY ELDER IS
LEADING AMONGST THE 40-PLUS WHO
ARE TRYING TO BE THERE, SHOULD
HE BE RECALLED, ARE YOU AMAZED
THAT 70 PLUS MILLION DOLLARS
THAT POURED IN THE PRESIDENT,
THE VICE PRESIDENT COMING INTO
CAMPAIGN, ELIZABETH WARREN, ARE
THEY GETTING PANICKED?
>> THEY ARE CERTAINLY SCARED.
GAVIN NEWSOM HAS POURED 10 TIMES
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY AS LARRY HAS
INTO THIS CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT
HIMSELF FROM BEING RECALLED IN A
STATE THAT IS ENTIRELY
DEMOCRATIC.
REMEMBER THERE IS A SUPER
MAJORITY IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR
DEMOCRATS AND NOW GAVIN
NEWSOM IS IN DANGER OF BEING
RECALLED.
IT'S JUST DEMONSTRATES HOW A GUY
WHOSE WIDELY PERCEIVED AS A
POSSIBLE PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE IN
THE FUTURE COLLAPSED IN LIKE A
DYING STAR BECAUSE HE'S SUCH A
POOR GOVERNOR OF THE STATE, THE
SAME STUFF THAT DROVE ME AND
MY COMPANY OUT OF THE STATE IS
COMING BACK TO HAUNT THE
DEMOCRATS.
AINSLEY: BEN THERE'S A
WHISTLEBLOWER INSIDE GOOGLE
THAT'S REPORTEDLY SAYING THEY
ARE UNDERGOING ANTI RACISM
TRAINING, WHY SUPREMACY TRAINING
, AND HOW TO PREVENT
BEING A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
IT FEATURES YOU AT THE BASE OF
THE PYRAMID CALLED THE WHITE
SUPREMACY PYRAMID, FEATURES YOU
AT THE BASE BEFORE IT WORKS ITS
WAY UP TO DIFFERENT INDIVIDUALS.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THIS?
>> IT'S PATHETIC, BECAUSE
GOOGLE IS THE MOST POWERFUL
COMPANY ON PLANET EARTH IN TERMS
OF INFORMATION DISSEMINATION.
IT'S PREVENTING INFORMATION AND
LIES TO ITS OWN EMPLOYEES AND
JUST DEMONSTRATING THE FACT THAT
CORPORATIONS HAVE GONE WOKE
BECAUSE THEY ARE FILLED WITH
COWARDS OR  ARE AFRAID OF THE
RADICAL LEFT BECAUSE THERE'S
NOTHING REMOTELY, REMOTELY
RELATED TO REALITY IN THIS
PRESENTATION.
I'M AN ORTHODOX JEW, I'VE BEEN
EXTRAORDINARILY OUTSPOKEN
AGAINST WHITE SUPREMACY TO THE
POINT WHERE THE FBI HAD TO
ARREST SOMEBODY TWO YEARS AGO
FOR THREATENING MY FAMILY,
GOOGLE PUSHING THIS KIND OF
STUFF DEMONSTRATES WHAT UTTER
YELLOW BELLY COULD YOU AFTERREDS
THEY ARE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
STEVE: THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
DOING WITH THEIR TRAINING OF
EMPLOYEES BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
GOOGLE THE SEARCH ENGINE, HAS
THEIR ALGORITHM IMPACTED YOU OR
YOUR BUSINESS?
>> WELL IT SORT OF DEPENDS ON
THE TIMING SO THERE HAVE BEEN
PROBLEMS WITH GOOGLE IN THE PAST
WHERE THE WAY THEIR SEARCH
ALGORITHM WORKS IS THAT RESULTS
THAT ARE UNFLATTERING TO
CONSERVATIVES COME UP REGULARLY
OR  THEY HAD A GOOGLE FACT CHECK
THAT WAS SPECIFICALLY DIRECTED
ONLY AGAINST CONSERVATIVE OUTLET
S NOT JUST MINE BUT OTHERS
, WE DO HAVE TO COPE WITH
THIS FROM TIME TO TIME, AND NONE
OF THAT IS REALLY SURPRISE TO
ANYBODY ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF THE
AISLE.
BRIAN:  BEN, BEST OF LUCK.
WE'LL SEE HOW THIS GOES AND
AGAIN, WE'RE ALL VACCINATED,
YOU'RE VACCINATED BUT FINDING
PEOPLE, DEMANDING UNVACCINATED
IS UNAMERICAN AND THERE'S GOING
TO BE